>> Hey Charles, how you doing?
>> I'm doing just fine Michael, how are you doing?
>> I'm doing pretty well, thanks. I'm happy to
get a chance to tell you about something today.
>> Excellent, and what is it you're going to tell me about?
>> We're going to talk about regression.
>> Like, progression? [LAUGH].
>> No, regression. So, let me tell you
about regression. So we are, in this section of
the class, talking about supervised learning. And Supervised
learning, in supervised learning we can take examples of
inputs and outputs and based on that we are going to be
able to take a new input and predict the corresponding output for
that input, right. So this, this covers all of this, this the
things we are talking about in the context of supervised learning, right.
>> Right.
>> Now, what makes regression special subtopic.
We are going to be talking about mapping
continuous inputs to outputs. As opposed to, what
was the other thing that we were mapping,
what other kinds of outputs did we think about?
>> Well, we had discrete outputs and continuous outputs.
>> Right, and so this is going to
be the focus on continuous. So regression seems
like sort of an odd word. It doesn't really kind of fit for this. So often
I think about regression as. So this is, this is me being all sad and sort
of reverting back to a childhood state. And
that's, you know, that's in the psychological sense,
that's what regression refers to. But it turns out that, that's not
what it means in this setting. But the story by which those
things became linked, I think, is kind of interesting. So let me
tell you about that. Okay. So, this is a picture of you Charles.
>> [LAUGH] Okay. I'll accept that.
>> You can tell it's you because he's really tall.
And you're, you're a fairly tall man. I know you
don't think of yourself that way, but you think of
everyone else as being short which is really the same thing.
>> Fair enough.
>> Alright, so let's say that this is Charles. Let's
say that this is someone of average height. Just someone at random.
>> Mm-hmm.
>> So now, let's pretend, Charles, that you have children.
>> I do have children.
>> All right. So let's, that's okay but we can just pretend, and
we want to ask the question what would you expect the average height
of your children to be? Would you expect it to be sort of,
you know, sort of Charles' height? Or
average height or may be somewhere between.
So let's let's actually ask this as a quiz.